logique tout de suite en compagnie
d'alain doublé ce qui est de claude
sicard quelques conseils pour
l'entretien de votre jardin en cette fin
novembre
fin novembre la nature ça arrange encore
pour que ceux qui aiment et armand
fleurs ne perdent pas le moral c'est un
prunier regardez ce magnolia il a des
bourgeons tout n'est pas mort loin de là
pourtant on ne pourra pas toujours
compter sur ses exploits de la nature
pour avoir des fleurs au printemps
il faut donc prévoir dès aujourd'hui on
dit qu'à la sainte catherine tout prend
1,6
c'est vrai ça mais c'est vrai c'est vrai
le dicton est pour vous
enfin au dieu merci on peut encore
planté après la sainte catherine donc on
est dans une période hors gel
on peut planter pendant tout l'hiver
pourtant même à la sainte catherine on
ne peut pas planter n'importe quoi alors
que faut il faire pour bien préparer
l'avenir parce que nous nous faisons ici
qui peut être fait par des particuliers
dans leur jardin ou même sur un balcon
ou dans un pot sur le bord d'une fenêtre
c'est à dire la mise en place des fleurs
pour le premier printemps
donc comme vous pouvez le voir derrière
nous avons mis en place des plantes qui
fleurissent un petit peu à cette période
et pourront fleurir durant l'hiver tant
qu'ils ne gèlent pas trop fort mais
viendront surtout en pleine floraison à
partir du mois de mars avril et jusqu'au
début mai parmi les fleurs qui peuvent
être mises en place dès l'hiver sous nos
climats pensées pâquerettes pin vert ou
mieux dit spies mais en attendant je
peux tout cela pousse profiter des
quelques roses qui vaillamment
résisteront jusqu'aux premiers grands
froids